[Music]
it's hard to confuse a jedi master with
a bounty hunter but in 1980 the
distinction wasn't as clear let's go
back in time to see what it was like to
watch the empire strikes back when it
was first released
while the empire strikes back is the
middle chapter of a trilogy many fans
initially felt it left too much to
interpretation in a letter to the
science fiction film magazine star log
one fan named sean bernard wrote i know
they wanted to leave something to settle
in the other sequels but they left a
little too much for instance han solo's
predicament the movie should not have
ended until han was either killed by
boba fett or jabba or rescued by lando
calrissian or chewbacca the former
preferably also the fate of bespin is
not told was it taken by lando's troops
taken by imperial troops or destroyed by
vader this criticism proved common
enough that film star harrison ford
responded to it in an interview with
rolling stone ford said one of series
creator george lucas's real strengths is
not giving you all the information you
need yet at the same time not denying
you anything essential you have a
feeling that you want to know more at
all times i have heard frequently that
there is a certain kind of
disappointment with the ending of the
second film i've heard people say
there's no end to this film or i can't
wait to find out what happens but they
will and that's exactly the effect
intended by the ending
i
am the father
this revelation from the empire strikes
back is often considered one of the most
shocking moments in movie history the
twist was so surprising in fact that
many fans in 1980 doubted what they just
heard star log reader robert l b d
scarola wrote is luke related to vader
most think so now that vader came right
out and said it well i say do you
believe everything you hear vader may
have lied just to enlist luke to his
side vader would then dispose of luke
once he got what he wanted even most of
the cast and crew were kept in the dark
as mark hamill explained on the graham
norton show in 2017 the version they
filmed had an alternate twist in that
scene the way we filmed it vader said
you don't know the truth obi-wan killed
your father
after filming the scene hamill said that
the director irvine kirchner pulled him
aside and told him that darth vader is
actually luke's father however he was
forbidden to tell anyone else including
his castmates that meant that even
harrison ford and carrie fisher didn't
learn the real line until they finally
saw a screening of the film
at the screening when that happened
harrison turned to me and said
hey kid
he didn't tell me that
another line that left fans scratching
their heads after the original
screenings of the empire strikes back
was something yoda said to ben
that boy is our last hope no
there is another
one star log reader named bill smith
theorized could it be vader himself
considering that there was an
equilibrium of power between the good
and dark sides of the force it would not
be impossible to turn vader into the
antithesis of what he is now especially
if luke is truly his son on the other
hand a fan named keith hoffman wrote i
suggest princess leia she is young
enough for the training she withstood
darth vader's tortures she is dedicated
to the cause princess leia not lando
heard luke's cries for help han solo is
not in shape to be going anywhere for a
while and he's too old i wouldn't be
surprised if in the third film leia
instead of luke destroys the emperor as
it turns out each of them was a little
bit right although not in the ways they
expected vader did switch sides at the
end of return of the jedi and leia
ultimately proved to be force sensitive
as well
i know is often considered one of the
most clever improvised lines in movie
history but not everyone felt that way
in 1980 starlog reader jeanette
vogelpole wrote somebody should tell
harrison ford that when a woman
passionately tells a man i love you i
know is not an acceptable response that
scene was not funny it was infuriating
another person who was not a fan of
ford's line was george lucas in a 2011
interview with john favreau the han solo
actor shared how the star wars creator
responded to his improvised line and
george i think that this is a fair
enough to say
he thought it was
horrible
and that it would get a bad laugh
however despite his distaste for ford's
version of the scene lucas allowed the
line to stay in for test screenings
where it was received favorably by
audiences
given how iconic that line is today it
seems like lucas made the right call to
let it remain in the film
while the empire strikes back wasn't
universally beloved upon its release
plenty of fans recognized it as a
masterpiece as soon as they saw it one
positive reaction came from star log
reader david k abernathy who wrote after
seeing the empire strikes back i came
away with the feeling that finally after
all these years science fiction has been
brought to the screen in all its glory
the empire strikes back is so rich so
full of mystery and excitement and most
of all wonder to me the empire strikes
back represents the first true science
fiction film with all of its parts
complete the characters the theme the
special effects and the magic it has the
right to be called the first science
fiction epic another star log reader
arlene berenberg wrote i didn't think
they could do it but they did they made
a movie that was better than the first
star wars more action more dimension to
the characters more and better effects
everything that made star wars so great
the first time plus much more the force
was certainly with george lucas when he
created this fabulous sequel
david gerald a science fiction author
and star trek television writer reviewed
the empire strikes back for star log
number 38 but was not very kind to the
film in his review he wrote just about
every other critic in the country has
been telling you how good the picture is
they've been falling over themselves to
tell you it's embarrassing i feel guilty
for not liking it as much as i'm
supposed to considering that star trek
relies more on grounded science than
star wars gerald's criticisms of the
empire strikes back were mostly about
how it disregarded real world logistics
he was frustrated by the many ways in
which its plot and characters seem to
ignore the physics of the world they
were in
let's go through this shower of
asteroids who cares
and my hair won't get messed up gerald
justified his criticism by reasoning
that the film was using science fiction
devices even if its plot skewed closer
to fantasy he also criticized luke's
growth but enjoyed other parts of the
movie including the musical score
performances production design and
effects
many star log readers were unimpressed
with gerald's review they struck back
heart in issue number 40 where a reader
named michael mallory wrote mr gerald
complains about what he deems
storytelling flaws in logic or science
and the empire strikes back as for the
scientific misrepresentations i can only
say they don't matter this is a fantasy
movie i'm tired of people faulting these
films for not being intellectual enough
who said they were supposed to be
thought provoking few films are perfect
nitpicking is like criticizing an apple
for not being steak when you're hungry
for steak it might be the best apple
you've ever tasted but it's still lousy
steak some letters to gerald were nicer
but overall they weren't the biggest
fans of starlog's official review
like gerald professional critics were
also initially mixed on the empire
strikes back and some of them were
downright savage about it washington
post critic judith martin wrote the
empire strikes back has no plot
structure no character studies let alone
character development no emotional or
philosophical point to make it has no
original vision of the future which is
depicted as a pastiche of other junk
culture formulae such as the western the
costume epic and the world war ii movie
its specialty is special effects or
visual tricks some of which are playful
imaginative and impressive but others of
which have become space movie cliches
frederick s clark of cine fantastique
magazine was also not a fan making a
prediction that really didn't age well
clark wrote the empire strikes back is a
lifeless copy of star wars propelled
chiefly on the momentum of that earlier
film without the likes of a peter
cushing or alec guinness to add some
dignity and solid support mark hamill
carrie fisher and harrison ford flounder
in roles that are certain to doom their
careers regardless of the series success
however as with the fans there were some
critics who loved the empire strikes
back right out of the gate the legendary
gene siskel of the chicago tribune gave
the film three and a half out of four
stars saying his only issues with it
were trivial compared to the strengths
of the film which are considerable and
sometimes even majestic
the empire strikes back was the
cinematic introduction of two characters
who would go on to be immortalized in
merchandise for decades to come yoda and
boba fett however arthur knight a critic
for the hollywood reporter confused them
in his review of the film knight's
column started out smoothly praising the
empire strikes back as the best science
fiction movie sent star wars he also
said that kirschner's direction made the
characters come alive even more than in
the previous film however two paragraphs
in night wrote as to the present episode
despite a couple of phoneded messages
from ben kenobi which collected must
last all of 40 seconds most of luke
skywalker's good advice comes from a
fascinating green hued character named
boba fett and i'm still not certain
whether he's a skillfully animated
puppet or a real live human being
whichever he's one of lucas's strongest
assets in this star wars incarnation
today the archived version of the review
begins with an update correcting the
error but it serves as an amusing
reminder that the icons of the present
were once still new and novel to fans
however even if he mixed up their names
knight was correct in his assumption
that both boba fett and yoda would go on
to count themselves among lucas's
strongest and most marketable assets
if some of the pushback against the
empire strikes back feels strangely
familiar even if you weren't around in
1980 there's a reason for that the
initial response to the empire strikes
back is eerily similar to that of 2017's
star wars episode viii the last jedi
both middle chapters of their respective
trilogies tried to take the star wars
franchise in exciting new directions and
both received mixed reviews from fans
who were initially displeased with the
wide gap between their expectations and
the film itself thanks to the internet
and social media the backlash against
the last jedi was much louder but the
parallels are still unmistakable many
fans slammed the last jedi for its
diversity and assumed political
correctness in addition to critiquing
the coherence of its plot of course few
fans in 1980 were complaining about the
empire strikes back being too
politically correct but there were
similar complaints about the story not
being coherent or compelling
mike ryan of uproxx mentioned in a 2019
interview with the last jedi writer and
director ryan johnson that the empire
strikes back also divided fans when it
was first released the filmmaker
admitted that even he himself was
initially disappointed with empire which
was actually the first star wars movie
he remembered seeing however he
eventually came to a census saying that
after watching and loving return of the
jedi he wound up warming to empire in
fact although he was initially a fan of
the empire strikes back it gradually
became his favorite of the trilogy so
perhaps if the last jedi follows in the
footsteps of its predecessor it may
someday be looked upon as fondly as the
empire strikes back check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about star wars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you